exactly a very clear connection between
the war which has been a disaster and
our economy which has been a disaster
the most clear link is the fact that the
war 2003 led to an increase in the price
of oil the price of oil was $25 a barrel
in 2003 futures markets will to look at
the demands and supplies going forward
saw that there was going to be an
increase in the demand for oil from
China India even the United States but
they thought that there was going to be
an increasing supply that was
concomitant with that increase in the
demand particularly for the Middle East
which is the low cost provider and so
they forecast that the price of oil
would remain around $25 a barrel for the
next 10 years well the war upset that
equation it was very difficult to
produce oil out of the Middle East and
and there were other things that went on
but clearly it was a very important
factor in the soaring of the price of
oil from $25.00 to 1514 outs back to 100
now why is that important well the
United States was spending hundreds of
billions of dollars in Saudi Arabia
Kuwait other places to producing oil in
the past when prices of oil went up like
that as in the 1970s it caused that
economic downturns spending that much
money abroad you don't have that much
money at home some people looked at what
was going on in American economy and
said well we repealed the old laws of
economics whenever anybody says that to
me I always say you know you're you're
not seeing something
going on and here it was very clear what
was going on